as news on the vaccine front continues
to change the very latest update
hits especially close to home thank you
for joining us at 11 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez the cdc announcing
today that one of the six across the
country
that had a rare reaction to the johnson
and johnson shot
was an 18-year-old woman from right here
in nevada
sasha loftus spoke with a medical expert
about this latest update
and she joins us now live outside the
las vegas convention center with more
sasha denise and brian the convention
center here is just one of many
locations that stopped administering the
johnson johnson shot
after it was put on pause for review but
the doctor i spoke with tonight said
even if you did receive the jansen
vaccine don't panic
when they first started talking about it
was like hmm you know what's going on
with this mary randina
shares her experience with the johnson
and johnson covett 19 vaccine
so i kind of got a lot of people on the
bandwagon to get the johnson and johnson
so when that
broke i was like oh no she didn't see
any serious issues
but was concerned to hear six women
across the u.s
developed blood clots after the one dose
shot an adverse event report came to us
from nevada
on wednesday the cdc revealed one of
those was an
18 year old here in our state with a
severe clot in her brain
less than one in a million chance of
this happening
dr warren volcker of intermountain
health care says cases like this
are rare as over 7 million people got
the jansen vaccine before it was put on
paws this week
every medication has some sort of risk
associated with
it as this unfolds i think we'll learn a
lot more about it
he added that the other vaccines on the
market pfizer and moderna
are still being administered safely i
would
definitely continue to recommend getting
the
vaccine that's available to you and as
for mary she's still glad to be
immunized
and encourages others to weigh the risks
and do what they
feel is right i think it's like anything
else you just have to be
hyper aware of your body
now the doctor said that usually any
kind of severe reaction that would come
for the johnson and johnson vaccine
would occur between 6 and 13 days after
you get the shot
now as for the woman who did have that
reaction here in nevada
the cdc reported that she is still being
treated tonight
reporting live in las vegas sasha loftis
8 news now